[Music]
after going through some of my old
videos i noticed one thing you guys seem
to enjoy getting rom-com recommendations
huh i think it's a pretty nice change of
pace from the usual content here on
vinnie tube so for today it's time for
another round of romantic comedy
recommendations
today we'll be going over 10 more
romantic comedies in anime
so without further ado let's jump right
into it
at number 10 is yamada and the seven
witches turning over a new leaf is a
really hard thing to do
especially if you're someone who's
already internalized delinquent behavior
ryu yamada
enters high school attempting to do so
only to fall back to his old ways
it didn't take long for him to go back
to being the lazy guy with all sorts of
delinquent behavior
on the other side of the spectrum is the
beautiful honor student urara the
complete opposite of our protagonist
she'd find her life on a collision
course with the resident delinquent
literally unfortunately this accident
allows them to discover the ability to
swap bodies with a kiss
a power that could end up being more
trouble than it's actually worth hence
yamada's foray into finding the seven
witches
seven students who've obtained powers
through kisses begins you can join in on
all of the freaky friday fun
too prepare for a fun ride as you join
arara and yamada in their mission to
solve the school's many supernatural
mysteries
for our ninth entry we have lovely
complex how
important should height be in the game
of love very much so it seems if you ask
risa koizumi and atsushi otani being
much taller than the average girl and
much shorter than the average guy
both do a number on them much worse
their respective crushes start falling
in love with each other now left with no
one but each other the duo then start
helping each other out with regards to
their crushes
however that's not the only thing
keeping them close stark differences in
height aside
the two share a lot of things in common
their love for music
fashion and their sense of humor you
know it's only a matter of time before
koizumi realizes her growing feelings
for othani would this be the start of a
mismatched yet somehow perfect romance
yeah this definitely sounds like
thoradora doesn't it just like doradora
i had a lot of fun watching lovely
complex it's just so way over the top
that i can't stop laughing and wanting
more with each passing episode if you're
up for some hilarious comedy starring
two
awkwardly paired characters with amazing
chemistry you should definitely try this
one out
[Music]
when it comes to showing youth romance
in its simplest and most straightforward
form i'd say that
zula children is king instead of a
full-blown anime series chronicling the
long
overarching development of romance
focusing on couples
this shows more of a series of skits
that showcases the various forms that
youth love can take
sure children has a whole slew of
colourful and interesting characters to
keep it fresh and you'd be amazed at the
number of ways the simple feeling of
i love you can be conveyed the drama's
there but overall the show is a
light-hearted comedic affair that
generally uses that part to entertain
despite the episodic and short anthology
nature of the show making it a bit
jarring to those accustomed to watching
full series sword israeli children still
does a whole lot of great things as a
rom-com given the nature of the source
material
i wasn't sure how the anime team would
pull this one off but what the hell they
did it
and they passed with flying colours
seventh in line is maiujiki not in
little part due to his experiences with
his family members kinjiro sakamichi has
developed a fear of women he can't even
take a touch from a girl before
suffering nosebleeds and even
fainting well things are about to get
worse for him largely in part to his
unfortunate encounter with renowned
butler subaru connoy turns out that the
popular butler is in fact a
shi and after a violent assault kinjiro
finds himself at the mercy of the
headmaster's daughter kanade in exchange
for kenjiro keeping subaru's gender a
secret gennady would help cure his fear
of women now i wasn't sure what my
expectations were into myojiki
seeing as i joined the ride due to
finding the opening theme really catchy
i got more than what i bargained for
because mao chiki gave me loads of fun
from its out of this world premise to
its endless doses of comedy
edgy and some cross-dressing hijinks
this show is an underrated winner
right before we enter the top five we
take a quick refreshing stop with maid
summer at number six
living a double life isn't easy
especially if you're someone as
hard-nosed and strict as student council
president misaki
known for her disciplinarian attitude
and martial arts skills that would send
even the toughest troublemakers running
she does hold a secret
she works part-time at a maid cafe it
doesn't take long before you sweet the
most popular guy in school walks into
the maid cafe and uncovers the
indomitable girl's secret
now he has her in the palm of his hand
what happens when the most popular bad
boy in school has the perfect blackmail
material an
opportunity for a budding romance of
course i think that the hook for maid
sama is really great
but i think it's got some issues with
the sheer amount of unimportant side
characters despite everything i still
think that there are things that he
could have done better
which is why it's only sixth on this
list however everything else from the
main character dynamics and development
the art and the sheer amount of comedy
especially in early episodes
makes this one a really good rom-com
at number five is school rumble i love
you
three magical words that are so powerful
that one wrong utterance
can turn multiple people's worlds upside
down that is
if you can even properly muster the
courage to say those magical words in
the first place
such is the dilemma faced by idiot
delinquent kenji haruma
who just can't find it in himself to
confess to his crush who in turn
is even more clueless in how she goes
with her feelings for an oddball
obsessed with food well you also have
these characters who may or may not have
feelings for kenji and what we have is a
full-blown high-octane comedy of
misunderstandings
failed confessions and plain old high
school craziness built around people
wanting to win the hearts of the people
they desire
and it looks like high school romance is
definitely not a walk in the park good
old school rumble is one of the shows
that opened me up to the world of
rom-coms
and i'm sure that a lot of you guys
could say the same and yeah you're not
supposed to take most of this one
seriously
wacky situations hilarious
misunderstandings and much more awaiting
one of the most beloved romantic
comedies of the 2000s
next up we take a look at sakuraso now
this hit light novel rom-com pretty much
defined part of my college life due to
his conscience preventing him from
abandoning a stray cat sonata ends up
being kicked out of his regular school
dorms and lands at sakura hall
home of the eccentric troublemakers
however his new life takes yet another
turn as he gets a quick request to pick
up the art teacher's cousin
mashiroshina all of serata's hopes of
protecting this new girl from the
craziness of the dorm get dashed when he
realizes that mashiro is also
quite the eccentric herself mashiro is
an artistic genius
but she's also one of the worst in terms
of social skills to the point where she
can't even take care of herself this
leaves serata to take care of this new
girl
who's wasted no time in latching onto
him there are so many ways that sakura
so could have ended up lost in the
shuffle in the admittedly oversaturated
genre
but it did manage to stand out with its
quirky characters
amazing dynamics and full dose of
entertainment i look back fondly on this
series and i think that you should
definitely definitely give it a shot too
[Music]
now beginning on top three is the third
ranked anime on the list ore monogatari
ori monogatari's main character takio
gorda is not exactly what you think of
when you think
rom-com protagonist sure he's got a
heart of gold in the sense of dashing
chivalry however he's also a giant of a
man whose intimidating frame gives him
his fair share of rejections
instead it's his handsome friend
sonakava who gets all the attention from
the girls that would change one day when
he rescues
rinko yamato from being molested even
after the sweet girl starts hanging out
with the duo
dakio assumes that she's just really
grateful and is actually interested in
sonakava little did he know that the
girl's actually
in love with him now that's a surprising
premise that you don't see every day
oreo monogatari is filled with a lot of
enjoyable lovey-dovey moments
while never ceasing to make me laugh due
to the awkwardness of it all the
characters
really have chemistry and while i think
the story moves forward in a rather slow
pace
the laughs i had were enough to have me
breeze through this show i was at the
edge of my seat wanting to see whether
takio's unexpected love story would
really bloom at the end of
[Music]
you might have known the show by name
already due to its recent popularity
but here we are in second place is bunny
girl senpai
dengeki bonko has struck gold with a
rom-com series again it seems you guys
know the basic setup for these shows now
don't you
standard average guy in this case sakuta
stumbles upon a chance encounter with a
girl
this time it takes the form of teen
actress mai sakurajima who our
protagonist sees in a bunny suit inside
the library
however sakura quickly realizes that
it's only he that can see mai
and he quickly concludes that mai's
affected by the urban legend that he
knows as adolescent syndrome with that
sakura decides to get to the bottom of
things while
unraveling the mystery of the adolescent
syndrome and he'd soon find out that
even more girls find themselves
afflicted with this mysterious
phenomenon
looks like here we have dengeki bunko's
answer to monogatari
because this show looks like it if
you've watched the latter you can
generally have an idea of what to expect
for bunny girl's senpai
it has its fair share of funny moments
but i found myself really gripped by the
level of drama
and tear-jerking that it can really do i
really recommend this show for a watch
and if you can't get enough of it
make sure to move on to the sequel movie
ever wanted to redo the joys of youth as
a boring old adult
real life might just be up your alley as
it's the number one show on this list
i've talked about this show multiple
times already but i'm surprised to see
that i've yet to feature it in a top 10
list for romantic comedies maybe because
i see it more of a romantic drama
but it has its funny moments and it does
give us a glimpse of the fun and joy of
youth
a lot of us could probably relate to
arata he's nearly the age of 30
juggling part-time jobs and simply
lacking direction in his life
all that changes once he gets offered
the job opportunity of a lifetime
project relife allows him to revert back
into a high school student
physically that is in a chance not only
experience youth once again
but to also fix some mistakes made in
the past now i'm not sure it's just
because of my age
but real life really poses a very
interesting question and premise that i
think a number of people can relate to
it does have quite a slow pacing but it
has a lot of touching moments and i
think it's very much worth your time to
watch it
so how does this list look 10 more
romantic comedies to help cheer you up
in these trying times and while you're
at it why not give some more
recommendations i need some fluffy and
light-hearted anime to help brighten
things up and have complete faith in you
guys to give some recommendations
yourself
if you enjoyed this video make sure to
hit the like button and hit the
subscribe button too
once we hit the next milestone i'll have
a surprise for you guys
till next time
[Music]
you